Profesora Tamar Gendler: Estamos
en el contexto del curso
y esta es nuestra segunda
conferencia sobre el castigo.
Recordarán que antes de la pausa
habíamos estado pensando
en los tipos de normas
morales apropiadas:
¿Qué tipo de principio subyace
en nuestra especificación de
las normas morales?
Ahora estamos viendo el mismo
conjunto de preguntas
desde el lado opuesto.
Observamos ese grupo de
preguntas desde la perspectiva
de lo que deberíamos hacer cuando
alguien trasgrede estas normas,
ya sea qua las normas morales o qua
las normas legales codificadas
en el conjunto de
estatutos de la sociedad.
Y observamos varias
justificaciones que podrían
ofrecerse
para la práctica del castigo.
Como dijimos brevemente, y hoy
diré un poco más,
acerca de las últimas dos de éstas:
restitución y rehabilitación.
Pero pasamos la gran parte
de la segunda mitad
de la conferencia del martes pensando en
la justificación retrospectiva,
que de muchas formas es análoga
al tipo de justificación
de limitación moral que vemos en
la imagen deontológica.
Lo que ahora quiero hacer es ver la
primera de éstas con algún detalle,
y reflexionar sobre la forma en que se
ve la imagen consecuencialista
o prospectiva del castigo.
Y pensar en las formas en que
los problemas que surgen
para un relato
consecuencialista del
castigo
parece hacerse eco de varios
problemas que surgen
de un relato consecuencialista más
general de la moralidad.
Así, sólo para recordarles cómo se ve
la caracterización del castigo
con la que trabajamos,
de la cual la cláusula más
importante será la primera,
haremos uso de la caracterización
clásica de mitad de siglo
del castigo
que viene de la tradición filosófica
legal anglo-estadounidense.
Y lo que es fundamental al reflexionar
en la justificación del castigo
desde una perspectiva consecuencialista,
es recordar que el castigo se hace en
respuesta a una ofensa legal,
lo realiza alguien que se
considera un delincuente, etc.
Pero también es algo que,
como parte del castigo,
supone la imposición de
algo desagradable
y de sufrimiento a quien se
aplican las condiciones 2 a 5.
Y la pregunta que tratamos de
respondernos a nosotros mismos
es cómo un estado puede
alguna vez justificar
el dar algo desagradable
deliberadamente a uno de sus
miembros.
Así, lo que la reducción de daño o la
perspectiva consecuencialista
dicen es que el único objetivo o la
única justificación del castigo
es impedir o disuadir
futuros actos de delito.
Los relatos consecuencialistas,
en sus formas puras,
sólo se interesan en las consecuencias.
Y en la medida que se preocupan
por la distribución
de utilidades a los miembros de
una sociedad, les interesa
aumentar al máximo la utilidad
desde ese momento en adelante.
Se les llama dirigidos a futuro
porque aunque pueden tomar
en cuenta el pasado,
en la medida que los recuerdos de
las personas lo hagan,
no lo hacen como algo relevante
para calcular la utilidad.
La única meta del castigo
es impedir o disuadir los
delitos en el futuro.
Y la única justificación del castigo
es impedir o disuadir los
delitos en el futuro.
Ahora bien, si un relato utilitario ha
de servir como justificación
del castigo como práctica, al ser
éste la forma deliberada
de aportar algo desagradable a un
miembro de la comunidad
que violó alguna norma legal
o moral, entonces,
para justificarse sobre bases
consecuencialistas,
que ese castigo es un
mecanismo eficaz y,
en algunos relatos, el más eficaz,
de aportar la disuasión de
futuros delitos.
Si hay alguna forma alterna
de aportar algún resultado
igualmente beneficioso,
entonces no podrá justificarse
sobre bases consecuencialistas
causar daño o
sufrimiento a una
persona.
Eso es lo que dice la imagen
consecuencialista.
Y observen que esta es la imagen
exacta de algunas perplejidades
en las que nos encontramos cuando
tomamos en cuenta cosas
como el caso del cirujano, en el que si
lo único que se toma en cuenta
son las distribuciones de la utilidad,
entonces muchos de los factores
que interviene en el razonamiento de
sentido común sobre los casos
parecen caer respecto de su relevancia.
Así, la sugerencia, si la
hipótesis empírica es correcta,
es que el castigo es el
mecanismo más eficaz
de prevención o de incapacitación.
Es decir, es la mejor manera
de impedir la posibilidad del delito
por parte del perpetrador,
y/o el mejor mecanismo para
disuadir el delito,
ya sea por esa persona o por otros que,
como resultado de hacer pública
la práctica del castigo,
llegan a reconocer cómo cambia que
lo que usted podría pensar
como el análisis de costo-beneficio
de realizar esa acción específica.
Así, Jeremy Bentham se hizo
famoso al decir que
--Jeremy Bentham fue el predecesor
utilitario de John Stuart Mill,
la persona que articuló originalmente en
la moderna tradición filosófica
cómo es que debemos pensar
del consecuencialismo.
Así, Jeremy Bentham se
hizo famoso al decir
que lo que hace el castigo es
cambiar el cálculo
de los costos y beneficios asociados
con un delito específico,
y unirlo a algo que por lo general tiene
algún tipo de costo benéfico,
de modo que pueda entrar en el cálculo.
En la literatura de condicionamiento y
refuerzo, el castigo es algo
que cambia las contingencias
asociadas con un acto específico.
Trae un castigo junto con una recompensa
a algo que por lo general
solamente tiene recompensa.
O bien, reduce la recompensa asociada
con algo que por lo general
trae una alta recompensa.
Esto debería estar claro para ustedes,
porque ya hablamos de la imagen de
esto en el caso positivo,
que pensar simplemente en términos de
justificaciones consecuencialistas
del castigo parece traer consigo
dos tipos de problemas.
El primero es que la
justificación
consecuencialista
parece sub-generar razones
para el castigo;
si recordamos que el castigo supone
la administración
deliberada de un daño.
Así, por ejemplo, muy bien podría ser,
con respecto de la pregunta de
la incapacitación,
que si nuestra única meta es
incapacitar a las personas
que probablemente cometan
delitos en el futuro
traerá no-utilidad a la
sociedad en su conjunto,
si nuestra única meta es
incapacitarlos,
entonces puede haber alternativas no
punitivas igualmente eficaces.
Recuerden la primera condición en
nuestra caracterización del castigo.
El castigo supone un estado de dolor o
sufrimiento impuesto por el estado.
Supone la aportación deliberada de
no-utilidad a una persona.
Se presume que la incapacitación simple
puede hacerse de tal manera que no
abarque ninguna otra cosa
que la cantidad mínima de
sufrimiento en la persona.
Así, no es posible justificar cualquier
cantidad mayor a la requerida
para la incapacitación sobre esta
base consecuencialista.
Además, parece ser, no sólo con
respecto a la prevención,
que hay na posibilidad de
incapacitación no punitiva,
pero siempre con respecto de la
cuestión de la disuasión.
Se supone que si la única
preocupación de uno
es disminuir la tasa de delitos,
entonces hay cosas que
mucho más baratas
que el sistema de prisiones, para
obtener esa meta deseada.
Crear situaciones sociales en que
las personas tengan acceso
a la educación y al empleo puede
ser (una pregunta empírica)
un medio más eficaz de disuadir el
crimen que el castigo público.
En particular si uno de los
resultados de poner en la cárcel
a las personas, muchas de las
cuales son padres de familia,
es dejar la próxima
generación de hijos
en una posición en la que el
tipo de hogares estables,
que por pláticas anteriores sabemos
que es lo que permite a las personas
tener almas bien ordenadas.
Muchos niños que crecen en hogares
que no les proporcionan ese
tipo de estabilidad,
puede tener costos sociales.
Permítanme reiterar que hay
preguntas empíricas.
Es una pregunta empírica si la forma
más eficaz de incapacitación
es aquella que, además, supone la
imposición de más sufrimiento
del que se requiere para la
incapacitación en el momento.
Tal vez tenga mejores
consecuencias de largo plazo
en términos de impedir delitos futuros.
Asimismo, tal vez la forma de
disuasión más eficaz
es un tipo de castigo que traiga
consigo una publicidad
que haga que los demás eviten
ese tipo de conductas.
Pero si resulta ser que la prevención
requiere una incapacitación sencilla
y que la disuasión parece más eficaz a
través de algunos otros medios,
el consecuencialismo no puede darnos
una justificación del castigo.
Así, el primer problema con el
argumento consecuencialista,
si se trata de encontrar una
justificación para el castigo,
es que sub-genera.
El segundo problema es que,
en ciertos casos,
parece sobre-generar castigo.
Así, parece, y lo leímos en
la obra de John Rawls
que leímos en la última clase,
dar permiso a lo que aveces
se conoce como "telishment"
(castigo ejemplar a un inocente).
Donde telishment significa
enfocarse en el telos,
concentrarse en la meta,
enfocarse en el fin,
más que hacerlo en el proceso.
Entonces, ¿adónde podría ir esto?
Este es un ejemplo.
Hay una comunidad de pastores.
Todos se parecen a Giges de Lidia.
Y ahí están todos, con sus caballos.
Llega nuestro tipo malo
común y corriente,
y se roba dos de los caballos.
La policía llega buscándolo.
Y deja el pueblo.
Así, no queda nadie a quién castigar
por haberse robado los caballos.
Pobre Jim, por mala suerte,
aparece justo en el momento
en que la policía llega
buscando a un perpetrador.
Y la policía se da cuenta que
una forma muy eficaz
de impedir el robo de caballos
en el futuro, tal vez,
sería meter a Jim a la cárcel
y escribir un gran articulo en el
periódico sobre ello:
"¡Ladrón de caballos capturado!
Sentenciado a cadena perpetua."
Es decir, el efecto disuasorio que
exige el castigo parece ser,
al menos en principio, como
si en ciertos casos
pudiera llevarse a cabo con la
misma eficacia castigando,
o con algo parecido al castigo,
a una persona que en realidad no es
quien cometió el delito.
Si la meta es la disuasión,
y si la hipótesis de que
publicar el castigo
es lo que produce la disuasión,
entonces parece ser que el
repertorio conceptual
no tiene recursos del
consecuencialista que niega el
"telishment".
Al igual que con los casos usuales del
cirujano que corta al paciente,
hay movimientos más complicados
de los que puede hacer el
consecuencialista.
Y la sugerencia es que no es imposible,
dentro de un marco consecuencialista,
dejar fuera algo como el "telishment".
La reflexión es que,
así como es importante tener claro de
qué recursos dispone usted,
si ésta es la
justificación a la que
apela.
Y reconocer, por lo menos
prima facie, que
la justificación consecuencialista
parece al mismo tiempo sub-generar
y sobre-generar cosas que parecen
castigos en los casos en que,
por lo menos como se codifica en los
estatutos legales que heredamos,
se violan las normas a las que las
personas se sienten atraídas
de manera intuitiva.
Entonces, ¿cómo podemos
evitar este problema?
Recuerden que parecía haber problemas
con la imagen retributivista
así como con la imagen
consecuencialista.
Una de las formas estándar de
evitar esto es introducir
lo que podría llamarse una
teoría de dos niveles.
En nuestra última clase
leímos un ejemplo
de una de las teorías de dos niveles
más sofisticadas e influyentes.
Así, John Rawls,
de quien escucharemos de nuevo
dentro de un par de semanas,
el filósofo político, escribió en la
década de 1050 un famoso documento
llamado "El concepto de las reglas",
en el que una de las dos cosas
que analiza es el castigo.
Y lo que sugiere es que
pensamos en la cuestión
de la justificación del castigo en
una formas más complicada.
Que lo primero que pensamos es que se
justifica la práctica en sí misma:
¿Qué hace que sea legítimo para una
sociedad el tener castigos?
Y la sugerencia es que lo que
justifica la práctica en sí misma
de tenerla es algo de la
llamada utilidad social.
Pero quena vez que establecemos la
práctica, lo que justifica
las acciones particulares dentro de la
práctica es la retribución.
Más adelante en el documento,
Rawls sugiere que
consideramos esta
distinción
entre justificar una práctica y justificar
las acciones dentro de la misma,
por analogía con las
reglas del béisbol.
Así, cuando establecemos las
reglas del béisbol,
podemos debatir si el béisbol
sería un mejor juego
si hubiera tres o cuatro strikes.
Si el béisbol sería un mejor juego
si el robo de bases estuviera
permitido o prohibido.
Si el béisbol sería un mejor juego
si los lanzadores fueran tratados
también como bateadores.
Así es el debate de la
naturaleza de la práctica.
Y usted podría pensar cuando debatimos
la naturaleza de la práctica,
entra en juego un tipo de
consideración.
Pero una vez que
instalamos la práctica,
no tenemos debates en el
contexto de un juego
acerca de si sería mejor, en
ese caso particular,
que un bateador pudiera
recibir cuatro strikes.
O si sería mejor, en ese
caso particular,
si una base robada cuente o no
como una forma de avanzar por las bases.
Así, podemos distinguir entre lo que
configura nuestra práctica
y lo que ocurre una vez que nuestra
práctica queda configurada.
Y la sugerencia de Rawls es que lo
que justifica la práctica,
en el caso del castigo, es una
imagen general de utilidad,
en tanto que lo que justifica los
actos dentro de la práctica
es algo como retribución.
Y la sugerencia es que esto
es capaz de resolver
dos problemas al mismo tiempo.
Resuelve el problema de la
sub-generación, en cierto sentido,
porque si la práctica
general no es útil,
entonces se abandonará la práctica.
Y resuelve con mayor claridad los
problemas de la sobre-generación
y del "telishment",
porque se descartan como un acto
dentro de la práctica.
Hemos establecido reglas de lo
que supone el castigo.
Éstos se justifican sobre
bases utilitarias.
Pero dentro de la práctica no
podemos hacer cosas
como meter a Jim a la
cárcel como disuasión,
porque está prohibido
dentro de la práctica.
Así, podría parecer que el
desafío o la solución pluralista
al dilema de cómo
justificar el castigo,
ya sea sobre bases retributivas
o consecuencialistas,
resuelve el problema que nos preocupaba.
Es decir, ¿cómo podría alguna
vez el estado justificar
el dañar a sus ciudadanos?
Pero creo que hay tres
preguntas que pueden hacerse
con respecto de esta solución.
Entonces podríamos preguntar
si la sola utilidad,
sin llamar a la retribución,
puede servir en realidad como
justificación única de la práctica,
o si de hecho el problema de
la sub-generación
simplemente resurgirá en el nivel de
justificación de la práctica.
Podemos preguntar si la
sola retribución,
sin llamar a la utilidad,
puede servir para justificar
acciones dentro de la práctica,
o si a la larga y a fin de captar qué
es lo que queremos castigar,
incluso una vez que hayamos
establecido la práctica,
requiere cierto atractivo a
la retribución.
Hablaremos de la psicología de
esto dentro de poco.
Y por último podríamos preguntar si,
dadas las distinciones de
los dos niveles,
hemos proporcionado cualquier cosa
como un relato coherente
de lo que justifica el castigo.
Si un tipo de razón rige la práctica,
y otro diferente gobierna la
aplicación de ésta,
entonces incluso si cada uno de ellos,
de manera independiente es capaz de
hacer ese trabajo, de hecho,
en especial si cada uno de
ellos en lo individual
puede hacer ese trabajo, uno
podría preguntarse
de qué manera los dos juntos
proporcionarían un relato coherente.
Así, eso cierra lo que quiero decir
sobre los aspectos
filosóficos generales
que fundamentan el castigo
como práctica.
Analizaremos dos de las
justificaciones estándar,
y luego una tercera que
intenta reconciliarlas.
Una vez más, permítanme recordarles
que lo que hacemos aquí
es pensar de manera más general
acerca de la justificación moral.
Así, todos los argumentos
que consideramos
en el contexto del castigo
tiene analogías directas en la imagen
especular positiva de ello.
En la segunda mitad de esta plática
quiero hablar de tres
preguntas adicionales.
Estas son las lecturas que
hicimos para hoy.
Quiero hablar de la psicología y las
limitaciones psicológicas
que parecen coartar
cualquier imagen de castigo
que vayamos a tener.
Eso irá de acuerdo con la forma en
que parece que las personas
responden de manera intuitiva
a ejemplos específicos de
violación a las normas.
Quiero enlazar lo que dijimos en
el contexto del castigo
con los temas de que hablamos
en torno a la suerte
al final de nuestras clases,
antes de la pausa de marzo.
Por último, quiero traer
algunos temas aristotélicos
acerca del carácter virtuoso, hablando
del castigo y la paternidad.
En los últimos 30 años, más o menos,
varios psicólogos sociales
extremadamente sofisticados
realizaron una gran cantidad de
investigación empírica,
observando las respuestas
de las personas
a casos hipotéticos y los códigos
legales de numerosas sociedades
en un intento no de llegar a la
cuestión normativa,
lo que justificaría el castigo;
sino una respuesta a la
pregunta descriptiva:
¿qué necesidad humana
necesita abordar el castigo?
Y al explorar estas
preguntas, John Darley,
de quien leímos selecciones en
varios puntos del curso,
incluyendo hoy, hace
atractivas sus discusiones
con la distinción de que
hemos hablado hoy,
con respecto de la cuestión normativa.
Así, pueden distinguir al
ver qué factores
afectan las decisiones de las
personas acerca del castigo,
ya sea que parezca que se llama
su atención hacia ellas,
hay preguntas de cosas como
desierto y retribución.
Es decir, preguntas:
¿afectan directamente la
probabilidad o qué tan severo será
el castigo, si pareciera como si
la persona en cuestión
pretendió hacer mucho daño,
independientemente de si tuvo
éxito en ello o no?
¿Afecta la evaluación de
tratar de dañar
si la persona, por ejemplo,
robó dinero para darlo a
una obra de caridad,
en comparación con haberlo robado
para comprarse un Ferrari?
Si preguntas como esa ocurrían en
la mente de la persona,
¿la persona pretendía dañar o no?
Si las preguntas acerca de las metas
respecto del botín del delito:
¿querían usarlo para algo
pro-social o anti-social?
Entonces parece como si uno de los
tipos de consideración
que intervienen cuando las personas
razonan acerca del castigo
son cosas respecto de la retribución.
Por contraste,
si cuando las personas piensan en el
tipo de castigo que impondrán,
lo que buscan son cosas como,
qué tan probable es detectar
un delito como este,
o bien qué tan público deberá
ser el acto del castigo,
entonces parece que los mecanismos
psicológicos subyacentes
detrás del castigo son los que son
particularmente delicados
para las limitaciones
consecuencialistas.
Así, en una serie de estudios en
las últimas décadas,
los psicólogos han preguntado,
¿a qué tipos de variaciones son
sensibles los juicios de castigos?
En general, cuando las
personas asignan castigo,
cuando las personas asignan severidad,
cuando las personas deciden
si castigar o no,
si se les da la oportunidad de
buscar información,
¿qué información, por ejemplo,
acerca del estado mental
o la motivación del delincuente?
¿O quieren información
acerca de lo ampliamente
publicitado que será el castigo
o qué tan probable es detectar
los delitos de esta clase?
Y resulta ser, con
bastante consistencia,
que las consideraciones del primer tipo
parecen impulsar las
respuestas de las personas.
Es decir, que un cálculo de utilidad
no parece ser la motivación primaria
cuando las personas analizadas en
estudios psicológicos,
o códigos penales, se
buscan como indicios
del mecanismo psicológicos que
subyace en el castigo.
Y veremos más evidencia en
favor de esta hipótesis
si consideramos un fenómeno
que a veces se conoce
como castigo altruista con costos
para terceras personas.
Así, estos son casos en los que
una persona, A, castiga:
es decir, proporciona daños y
costos a otra persona,
de una forma que, antes que
nada, traen un costo a A,
no le aporta beneficios
directos a A, y trata de
una violación de normas que no
afectó a A en primer lugar.
Así, estoy formado en una larga cola,
esperando obtener mi iPad 2,
y una persona se mete a la
cola detrás de mí.
Exacto: se mete a la cola
detrás de mí.
No afecta mi acceso al iPad.
Podría castigarlo invitando a todos
los que están detrás de mí
a meterse delante de nosotros dos.
Eso me perjudicaría a mí, ¿no?
Dejé que todos los que
estaban detrás de mí
meterse delante.
No me beneficia de ningún modo.
Y la razón por la que causo daño a la
persona detrás mío no es algo
que tenga que ver con una violación
de las normas dirigida a mí.
Se metió a la cola detrás de mí.
Y vemos caso tras caso de
conductas con esta estructura
en la literatura de la
economía conductual.
Aparece por cualquier razón.
Tal vez porque esta es un
modo de promover
cierto tipo de prosocialidad
estable en lo evolutivo.
Tal vez porque las violaciones a las
normas entran a lo heurístico,
que hace que las personas
actúen en ciertas formas.
Tal vez por una tercera razón.
Parece que en numerosos entornos,
tanto de laboratorio como públicos,
las personas toman parte
en actos punitivos
que tienen la estructura
articulada arriba.
El consecuencialismo, al menos en
su forma más sencilla,
no puede explicarlo.
Por último, el estado de
mente parece desempeñar
una función importante en la forma
en que las personas responden
a situaciones que suponen un
castigo potencial.
Así, supongan que el pobre
Jim entra a mi casa,
y escondido detrás de la puerta se
encuentra mi valioso paraguas.
Jim toca a mi puerta; yo le
digo, "adelante".
Y Jim cruza la puerta y se tropieza
con mi valioso paraguas,
de modo que se golpea y
perfora un agujero en él.
Y él dice, "¡Oh, no! ¡Tu
valioso paraguas!" Caso uno.
Caso dos, Jim aparece en mi casa.
Le digo mientra toca a la puerta,
"Jim, ten cuidado con mi
paraguas al entrar".
Jim abre la puerta y se tropieza
con mi valioso paraguas,
haciéndole un agujero, y dice,
"¡Maldita sea, tu paraguas!"
Caso número tres: Jim toca a mi puerta.
Le digo, "Jim, atención
con mi paraguas".
Jim abre la puerta, pisa mi
valioso paraguas y,
levantando el pie, dice, "¡Sí!
¡Le acerté a tu paraguas!"
¿Qué tipos de respuestas
evocan los tres casos?
Aquí está nuestro famoso Malómetro,
que recordarán de otros varios casos.
Cuando Jim accidentalmente se
tropieza con el paraguas:
el primer caso, cuando
dije, "entra, Jim",
y él lo pisó y dijo,
"¡Oh, no, tu paraguas!"
Hay un daño, pero se maneja
a un nivel muy bajo.
Cuando le digo a Jim,
"¡Cuidado, mi paraguas!"
No obstante, Jim abre la
puerta, se tropieza y dice,
"¡Maldita sea, tu paraguas!"
Hizo algo negligente.
Y hay un sentido, por parte de la
mayoría de las personas,
de que algo ligeramente peor ocurrió
en una dirección generalmente mala.
Y cuando Jim entra a mi casa
y pisa mi paraguas,
y mira orgulloso lo que hizo, parece
ser que de manera intencional,
hay, por parte de la
mayoría de las personas,
una sensación de que
ocurrió algo peor.
Por sí solo, el consecuencialismo
no puede explicar esto.
En los tres casos, obtengo un
paraguas perforado.
Lo que puede explicar esto es una
respuesta que las personas
parecen bastante persistentes
en todas loas culturas,
que es algo llamado el fenómeno
de la indignación moral.
En el caso del accidente, no hay
indignación moral en absoluto.
Nadie piensa que Jim fue
moralmente indignante
al pisar en mi paraguas, ya que no sabía
que estaba detrás de la puerta,
y entró como respuesta a mi
solicitud de que lo hiciera.
En el caso negligente, hay
cierta irritación,
hay cierta indignación moral,
hay una sensación:
"Jim, te dije que mi
paraguas estaba ahí".
Pero la indignación moral es
relativamente baja.
Pero en el caso en el que Jim hizo algo
que nos parece una causación
intencional de daño,
en transgresión directa a mi
solicitud de no hacerlo,
"Jim, ten cuidado con mi paraguas",
hay una respuesta de alta
indignación moral.
Lo que Carlsmith y Darley sugieren, en
el artículo que leímos hoy,
es que estas actitudes de
indignación moral nula,
baja o elevada,
dirigen nuestra atención a
diferentes partes del episodio.
Cuando ocurre un evento que no nos
causa ninguna indignación moral,
no hay, excepto en lo
referente al deseo general
de hacer del mundo un mejor lugar,
atención ni a la víctima
ni al perpetrador.
Ocurre algo malo.
Podríamos recorrerlo tratando
de cambiar el mundo.
Si tengo otros paraguas en mi coche,
podría traer uno de ellos.
Pero en general, cuando las cosas
ocurren por accidente,
el perpetrador no es el
foco de atención.
Y la víctima no es más un enfoque
de atención de lo que sería
si esto fuera consecuencia como
resultado de una ráfaga de viento
que hubiera destruido el paraguas.
En los casos de baja indignación moral,
la atención se dirige a la victima.
Hay una tendencia a
concentrarse en la
compensación,
en la necesidad de mejorar las cosas.
Pero no hay enfoque en el perpetrador
como alguien que necesite nuestra
atención punitiva concentrada.
Pero en el caso,
y dentro de un momento voy a
pedirles que saquen sus controles,
porque vamos a hablar de
acción intencional.
En el caso en el que el acto
que viola la norma moral
parece haber sido intencional,
hay una tendencia a enfocarse no
sólo en la compensación,
sino también en el castigo.
Este es un patrón
extraordinariamente
resistente,
y parece muy interesante desde el
punto de vista psicológico
si tratamos de proponer códigos morales
que parecerán satisfactorios
a los seres humanos más evolucionados.
Pero un problema con esta
imagen es que resulta ser
que determinar si una acción se
hizo de manera intencional,
puede muy bien ser más complicado de
lo que apareció inicialmente.
Así, mi colega y compañero
catedrático de Yale, Joshua Knobe,
hizo una maravillosa serie de
estudios sobre la pregunta
de si esto lleva a las personas a pensar
que una acción se realiza de
manera intencional.
Y realizaremos el estudio en la
forma que todos ustedes
obtendrán ambas imágenes.
Así, no obtendremos la
distribución exacta
de lo que es indicativo de las
respuestas típicas.
Pero creo que no deja de ser interesante
que piensen en los casos.
¿Cuántos de ustedes han visto
este tipo de casos antes?
Sólo manos.
Muy bien, aproximadamente 5%
a 10% de ustedes.
Así, Josh Knobe presenta el
tema con escenarios,
imágenes como las siguientes.
El vicepresidente de una empresa va
con el presidente del consejo
y dice, "estamos pensando en
comenzar un nuevo programa.
Nos ayudará a aumentar las utilidades,
pero también perjudicará
el medio ambiente".
El presidente contesta,
"no me interesa dañar el
medio ambiente.
Solamente quiero ganar tanto
dinero como pueda.
Comencemos el nuevo programa".
Comienzan el nuevo programa.
Por supuesto, el medio
ambiente se daña.
La pregunta es esta: al
comenzar el programa:
"no me preocupa dañar el
medio ambiente,
sólo quiero ganar tanto
dinero como pueda",
¿el presidente dañó el
ambiente de manera intencional?
¿El presidente, uno: sí, dañó el
ambiente intencionalmente;
dos, no dañó el ambiente de
manera intencional?
¿Eh? Las personas no tienen
que sacar los controles.
Solamente hay 70 de ustedes.
Muy veamos qué pasó.
Así, 77% de ustedes piensa
que dañó el ambiente de
manera intencional.
Ahora probemos el segundo caso.
Segundo caso: traten de olvidar lo
acaba de pasar en el primero.
Sé que no pueden, pero
traten de hacerlo.
El vicepresidente de una empresa
va con el presidente del consejo y dice,
"estamos pensando en comenzar
un nuevo programa.
Ayudará a aumentar las utilidades.
Pero también ayudará al
medio ambiente."
El presidente contesta,
"no me interesa ayudar el
medio ambiente.
Solamente quiero ganar tanto
dinero como pueda.
Comencemos el nuevo programa".
Comienzan el nuevo programa.
Por supuesto, el medio ambiente mejora.
El presidente contesta,
"no me preocupa en absoluto
ayudar al medio ambiente.
Solamente quiero ganar dinero".
Pregunta: ¿el presidente ayudó al
medio ambiente intencionalmente?
Uno, si la respuesta es sí.
Dos, si es no.
Veamos cómo salen los números.
¡Guau! ¡Ustedes son sorprendentes!
Fueron mucho más unánimes que
los resultados normales
de Knobe, incluso cuando les di
ambos casos en secuencia,
lo que debió haber mitigado el efecto.
Pero aquí vamos.
De manera clásica, cuando se
presenta esto a las personas,
en el primer escenario cuando 77%
de ustedes dijo que sí,
que lo dañó intencionalmente,
más o menos 83% dijo que lo hizo.
Pero en el segundo caso,
cuando ustedes dieron ese
sorprendente 89%
a que no ayudó al ambiente de forma
intencional, por lo general
este número (aclaración, lo hizo
intencionalmente) es 23%.
Entonces, este es (aclaración: no
ayudó intencionalmente) 67,
perdón, 77%.
Muy bien, adónde nos lleva esto?
Permítanme recordarles lo
que acaba de pasar.
Tuvimos dos escenarios idénticos.
La única diferencia fue que
cambiamos "ayudar"
por dañar" en el primer caso.
En ambos casos, lo que el
presidente dijo fue,
"no me interesa la cosa que
piensas que hiciste
en el primer caso,
ni la cosa que no piensas que hiciste
intencionalmente en el segundo.
Lo único que quiero es ganar dinero".
Así, algo que ignoraba en
el primer caso,
y que la mayoría de ustedes creía que
era algo que pretendía hacer.
En tanto que algo que ignoró
en el segundo caso,
casi ninguno de ustedes pensó
que intentó hacerlo.
Eso es desconcertante si lo que
ocurre aquí es que se supone
que el castigo debe seguir a la
acción intencional.
Debido a que parece que el
tipo de acción
que consideramos
intencional de alguna
manera
se confunde con los tipos de
acciones que emprendemos
para ser moralmente problemáticos.
Entonces, lo que complica mucho
más toda la pregunta
sobre cómo pensamos sobre el
castigo de lo que ya era.
Pero hagamos eso a un
lado por el momento
y pensemos en las implicaciones que hay
desde los resultados
psicológicos que hemos
estudiado.
Por un lado, parece que, desde el
punto de vista psicológico,
prestar atención a las razones
retributivas o retrospectivas del castigo,
al reequilibrio de las
escalas de justicia,
se requiere psicológicamente para la
teoría de sentirse satisfecho.
O por lo menos, ese simple
ver hacia delante
y pensar en las consideraciones
consecuencialistas y la utilidad
no parecen suficientes en
lo psicológico.
Así, la pregunta es si hay una
alternativa adicional al tomar en serio
la psicología humana.
Y un número de psicólogos y
filósofos se han hecho la pregunta
de si no vemos hacia
delante ni hacia atrás,
hacia el desempeño del crimen
como algo que exige un reequilibrio
de las escalas de justicia,
o bien hacia la utilidad que puede
aportarse a la sociedad,
sino más bien a las cosas que
llamamos tres y cuatro
en nuestra caracterización inicial,
en la restitución y
rehabilitación como
motivaciones,
de alguna manera podemos
obtener un relato psicológicamente
satisfactorio del castigo,
donde las metas no sean el
reequilibrio o la utilidad,
sino más bien algún tipo
de reparación?
Esto a veces se conoce como justicia
restaurativa o reparativa.
Aquellos de ustedes a quienes les
intrigue, les indico un lugar
en donde podrán leer
artículos acerca de este tema.
Muy bien, eso cierra la primera
parte de nuestra discusión,
las implicaciones
psicológicas del castigo.
En la segunda mitad de esta plática
quiero hablar de tres
preguntas adicionales.
El próximo Martes
comenzaré la plática
hablando de la conexión en el
contexto de la paternidad.
Así, en esta unidad hemos pensado
en los casos como este,
donde la suerte parece tener un
papel en las consecuencias.
Cuando la persona no
pretendió causar daño.
La Llamada telefónica y la
Alerta desafortunadas
no tuvieron deseo de dañar al niño.
Pero por supuesto, la suerte puede
tener una función en los casos
en los que alguien trata de
dañar de manera deliberada.
Así, es nuestro chico malo normal,
que aparece en el pueblo cuando
hay una víctima potencial.
Saca la pistola y dice,
"muy bien, voy a dispararle a ese tipo".
Y tiene a la suerte de su lado.
La intención se lleva a cabo en la
forma en que lo planeó,
y tiene éxito.
Su perfecto análogo, "Tirador
desafortunado", aparece en el pueblo
y dice, "voy a dispararle a ese tipo".
Pero cuando jala del
gatillo, por desgracia,
en el momento en que la bala debía
alcanzar a la víctima prevista,
interviene la suerte de la última
historia y detiene en seco a la bala.
Así, no tiene éxito en el
delito que trató de cometer.
Observen que esto es el análogo
opuesto del caso anterior.
La intención en ambos
casos es la misma.
La acción en ambos casos es la misma.
Pero en el primer caso, el
delincuente tuvo suerte
respecto de la meta que buscó.
Le disparó al tipo al que
quería dispararle.
En tanto que en el segundo caso,
el delincuente no tuvo suerte
respecto de las metas esperadas.
No pudo dispararle a su víctima.
La pregunta sería
por qué castigamos con mayor
severidad a éste que a este otro.
¿Qué tipo de justificación
podría subyacer en esto?
David Lewis, en su bastante
complicado, lo admito,
documento que debieron leer para hoy,
y del que les prometo que
hablaremos en partes,
para ayudarlos a entender la
lógica del argumento,
pero David Lewis sugiere que lo
único que podría justificar
tratar este acto como más
punible que este otro,
es si pensamos que estaría bien imponer
lo que él llama "lotería penal".
Así, lo que dice es, si
sabemos de manera objetiva
que cuando se participa en un tiroteo
en el que se jala del gatillo,
hay una probabilidad en diez de
que su acción sea justa,
y nueve de que tendrá éxito,
entonces castigarlo es
fundamentalmente, en nuestro
sistema,
equivalente a hacerlo sacar un popote
entre un conjunto de éstos
en el que hay nueve que lo enviarán a
la cárcel por mucho tiempo
y uno que lo enviará por poco tiempo.
Y sugiere que podemos ver que
nuestra práctica actual
es similar a eso al darles una
serie de casos imaginarios,
de los cuales cada uno
tiene la misma justificación
que el dibujo del popote.
Entonces, imaginen un sistema en
el que una vez que hayamos
establecido que la intención fue
igual en los dos casos.
Hicimos que estas dos
personas sacaran popotes.
Cada uno de ellos tiene una
probabilidad en diez
de salirse con la suya: lo
siento, una en diez.
Y nueve de diez de acabar en la cárcel.
Eso corrige la suerte.
Lewis dice que eso no es equivalente
a que la persona saque el popote,
sino a que lo haga un
representante del tribunal
antes de que se celebre el juicio.
Y si bien el jurado simplemente decide,
"¿tuvo la intención de hacerlo?"
no saben de antemano cuál
será el castigo.
Sugiere que eso es
equivalente, de antemano,
a que el representante del tribunal
saque el popote y haga público
que si lo condenan por la
intención de cometer el delito,
entonces recibirá el castigo nueve, es
decir, el más severo, o el uno.
Lewis sugiere que eso es
equivalente a que, de antemano,
proporcionemos una
reconstrucción del delito,
con probabilidades similares, y si en
ese caso la víctima muere,
entonces la persona recibirá
un castigo más severo.
Y Lewis sugiere además que
nuestra práctica actual
de dejar que el mundo
resuelva esto solo,
de modo que castiguemos con mayor
severidad a la persona
cuyo intento criminar tuvo mayor éxito
que al que no lo tuvo,
no es más que una
pre-representación equivalente
moralmente
a sacar popotes en un sorteo.
Cerraré con esto como una forma de
tratar de sacar a la luz
la perplejidad de la moral o, tal
vez, la suerte inmoral.
Y el próximo martes abriremos con
nuestro análisis de Kazdin
y pasaremos a nuestra selección
de los escritos de Thomas Hobbes.
Mañana publicaré esa
lectura para ustedes.
Gracias.